foreign
movies like Raya and The Last Dragon
Moana Frozen 2 and Pixar's latest
production called Elemental have in
common they're teaching the basic
fundamentals of Elemental witchcraft
[Music]
in the past few years people have joined
witchcraft in incredible numbers and I
believe that it is because they are
putting these things in movies and many
people are unaware of what they are
here's some examples of how many movies
use the elemental witchcraft as part of
their storyline Shrine of the four
elements Earth Fire and Water imagine
hazards and when heat control the four
statues he was Master of the four
elements
figure which represents the four
elements it represents the
stuff this magic comes from four
elements fire water Earth and air at the
center of the Food Lion wrench before
Ellen
others must be the four elements of the
Monty Athens worshiped four hours
Elemental witchcraft is the use of earth
wind fire water all centered around the
fifth element which is Spirit this is
the basic building blocks of magic so
listen to what these real life wicked
witches and how they teach about the use
of magic my name is B I have been a
practicing head twitch for 12 years so
when you call Circle you address each
one of the elements
um in their various directions and you
ask them to join you in your Sacred
Space so pay attention to the way that
she talks about calling a circle
addressing the elements and inviting
them into your Sacred Space that's going
to be important when we look at Frozen
and how Elsa calls Circle the basic
introduction to Witchcraft is learning
how to work with these elements I am
going to be talking about some like
beginner Concepts and what's craft 101
today we are going to be Focus focusing
on the five elements of Witchcraft and
calling circle with them earth air fire
water and spirit and we use all five of
these within witchcraft to create Magic
hi my name is Benja I'm the Norris witch
so the elements that witches work with
nowadays are water earth air and Fire
so in my opinion the elements are a very
basic thing that you should to learn
early on when you're getting into
witchcraft there's even a book called
Elemental witchcraft that witches
promote for you to learn how to work
with magic I'm excited to finally share
my review of Elemental witchcraft
turning the wheel through Elemental
witchcraft so you go through each of the
elements you have earth air fire water
and you also have spirit so very
interesting that Pixar's latest
production called Elemento they
literally dropped the word witchcraft
but it's still discussing Earth Wind
Fire and Water Leviticus 20 verse 6 and
the soul that turneth after such that
have familiar spirits and after Wizards
and goes a horn after them I will even
set my face against that soul and will
cut them off from among his people so
the Bible is very clear on us having
nothing to do with talking with Spirits
or engaging in magic and sorcery but yet
that's exactly what they're teaching in
some of these kids programs which brings
us to Frozen 2 the very theme of this
movie is Elsa learning and finding the
four elements and looking for The Fifth
Element you know air fire water and
Earth yes a look
said to be a bridge between us and the
magic of nature
of this Spirit some say they heard it
call out the day the forest fell my
father heard it do you think that's
who's calling me she's basically telling
you that the kingdom fell because of the
communication with these spirits and
messing with magic yet Elsa feels like
it's not bad I woke the magical Spirits
at the Enchanted Forest wait the
Enchanted Forest
the one father warned us about yes why
would you do that because of the voice I
know it sounds crazy but I believe
whoever is calling me is good how can
you say that look at our kingdom I know
my magic can feel it I can feel it
this is not a small part of the theme
all throughout Frozen she's literally
looking for these spirits
the basic fundamental understanding of
Witchcraft is when Nature speaks you
listen we only trust nature when Nature
speaks
we listen
[Music]
Earth Giants
what if I can settle them like I did the
Wind and Fire remember the goal is to
find the voice find the truth and get us
home here is Elsa addressing all four of
these elements which is the basic
building blocks of witchcraft
fire water Earth there's even necromancy
in the storyline in Frozen two when Elsa
is thought to be dead and she hears her
grandfather speak listen to what he says
understand grandfather we bring
arendelle's full guard but they have
given us no reason not to trust them
the north Ultra follow magic which means
we can never trust them father magic
makes people feel too powerful too
entitled it makes them think they can
defy the will of a king that is not what
magic does that's just your fear fear is
what can't be trusted in this storyline
you have a father that's telling you if
you mess with magic it will produce a
confidence in you to even defy the will
of a king do you want your child to
learn those kind of Concepts thinking
about them spiritually when Elsa decides
that she really wants to see this spirit
being that is supposedly calling her or
talking to her she sings this really
interesting song
[Music]
who's the way the Bible talks about
Jesus as being the way the truth and the
life
[Music]
this is witchcraft 101 she's literally
calling the elements in their directions
into her space so when you call Circle
you address each one of the elements
and in their various direction and you
ask them to join you in your Sacred
Space
[Music]
but the allegory doesn't stop here in
the very end of the story when Elsa's
thought to have died Anna meets up with
her and look at how she rides up on a
horse wearing white that's a parallel to
what happens in The Book of Revelation
is it really you Anna
I thought I'd lost you lost me you saved
me and Anna Arendelle did not fall it
didn't the spirits all agree Arendelle
deserves to stand with you you did what
was right for everyone
find the fifth spirit
[Music]
you are the fifth spirit
you are the bridge well actually a
bridge has two sides and mother had two
daughters
we did this together
and we'll continue to do this together
you're okay
you look different did you cut your hair
or something or something listen to how
they talk about the kingdom falling and
the world didn't fall and Elsa didn't
die and then she says I'm the bridge the
fifth spirit in witchcraft that fifth
spirit is literally Satan look at what
is in the storyline of Moana you have
the Earth Spirit the Fire Spirit the
water spirit all of these Elemental
witchcraft things are present even in
this story when it has Moana talking to
her dead grandmother that's called
necromancy when you're speaking to the
Dead the Bible specifically talks about
we should have nothing to do with
speaking to the daddy
voice starts to whisper
Moana
[Music]
me
I know the way
once again the Bible describes Jesus as
the way the truth and the life but here
this story is planting the idea saying
that what I was looking for out there is
actually something that is inside of me
that fifth Spirit there shall not be
found among you anyone who burns his son
or his daughter as an offering or anyone
who practices divination or tells
fortune or an interpreter of Omens or a
sorcerer or a charmer or a medium or a
necromancer or one who inquires of the
Dead for whoever does these things is an
Abomination to the Lord and because of
these Abominations the Lord your God is
driving them out before you why because
the spirits that they think they're
talking to are not just spirits of
somebody that was living before they're
actually demons and we find the same
elements in Raya and The Last Dragon
each one of the Dragons represents a
different element and when they put
their magic together they create the
fifth Spirit let's go all the way back
to Pocahontas but grandmother willow
what is my path all around you are
spirits child they live in the Earth's
water the sky if you listen they will
guide you I hear the wind yes what is it
telling you
so describing that their Spirits all
around you and that you should listen to
them is a theme that we're starting to
see in all of these Productions
I can hear you and when that voice
starts to whisper Moana listen
it calls me
all around you are spirits child they
will guide you I hear the wind
[Music]
foreign
don't leave me alone
[Music]
the Bible describes a time when Satan is
able to counterfeit these elements of
the earth even bringing fire to come
down from heaven in the sight of men and
he deceives those who dwell on the Earth
by these signs so we see that Satan can
control the elements of the earth and
what does that actually do it breaks
people's confidence in God because when
you see a miracle something that is
outside of human understanding then you
have to attribute that to a higher being
either God or like an elemental
witchcraft if they use the elements in a
certain way or they can control them
then what they're doing is taking the
power away from God and putting it back
in the hands of man this is why
Elemental witchcraft is a counterfeit
for the miracles of god the Bible says
in Revelation 18 23 that the end of the
world world will deal with a deception
that uses sorcery so paying attention to
all these stories that have these
elements in the magic sorcery witchcraft
these are literally numbing your mind to
these things and we know that these are
going to be used in the end of time and
this brings me to Pixar's latest movie
called Elemental
element City Air usually has their head
in the cloud Earth can be a little seedy
nothing weird going on here water is
always getting into something
oh and fire we run a little hot
if you describe a person or place as
seedy you disapprove of them because
they look dirty or messy or they have a
bad reputation notice how they said
water gets into everything are we
supposed to get into everything or did
God actually build fences and boundaries
over what we should or should not get
involved in and fire having a temper
that is hot or they run a little hot is
not always a good thing Proverbs 29 11
says a fool gives vent to his Spirit but
a wise man holds it back Proverbs 14 29
says whoever is slow to anger has great
understanding but he who has a hasty
temper exalts Folly and Proverbs 16 32
says whoever is slow to anger is better
than the mighty and he who rules his
Spirit than he who takes a city so these
are not characteristics that are
necessarily good ones look at how this
story sets the stage that everybody
lives by only one rule we all live by
one simple rule
so once again we see in the story
there's a rule and we start to see all
of these elements begin to break the
rules
oh
so you've never left firetown sorry
buddy elements don't mix
hey plus my dad would boil you alive why
does anyone get to tell you what you can
do in your life so look at this
spiritual parallel here there's a father
that's telling you to live by the rules
and yet they're beginning to set the
stage of these elements begin to break
the rules they begin to mix yet nothing
happens to them
I've been trying to fill my father's
shoes but I never once asked what I
wanted to do
isn't this a message that is pregnant to
the times that we're living in today
that there's some sort of rules that
that there's a father that's telling us
to live by those rules yet in this story
she's like why do I want to live by
somebody else's rules I've never asked
what I want to do even showing you that
there is fences that should not be
crossed yet they cross those fences and
once again nothing happens
why do they even have these who knows so
the basic message of this particular
production is in line with the message
that Satan has been saying from the
beginning you need to live however you
want to live and don't listen to the
advice that God gives so don't let these
movies Place seeds into you or your
child's mind that witchcraft is okay to
play with that even though the Bible
tells us not to get involved in these
things that nothing big or no big
consequence is going to come out of this
let's steer clear of these kind of
things that are planting messages in
your mind that are different than what
God wants for us in our lives
[Music]
thank you